The answer is the box over here.
Some of you might have chosen this box, but I'll tell you in a second why this is the better box.
This is the resulting pie chart where the red class is 20-32,
and the remaining  black class is the age group 33 and older.
Now let's do the math.
To understand what area the red curve will occupy, we're going to divide 96,000
by the total number of students, which is 96/144.
It happens to be the same as 8/12.
Now, the 8 mark is the one over here, but I chose the 9 mark.
This is the 9 mark--1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
The reason is one mark has already been used up by the first class,
and now we incrementally add 8 to those to arrive over here.
The surface area in the pie shown in red really corresponds to 8/12 of the total surface area.
If we now plug in the final class of 36,000 students, which is the same as 36/144 or 3/12,
you'll find this area over here occupies exactly 3/12 of the total area.
Hence this is the correct pie chart.